hands
shots fired a shootout at a Motel 6
caught on body camera video after a
suspect begins firing at sheriff's
deputies
shots fired shots fired the shooting
happened on May 16th in Anderson Indiana
about an hour north of Indianapolis
Madison County sheriff's deputies
arrived at the Motel 6 to serve warrants
to Brooke Badger and John nicca body
camera video shows the sheriff's deputy
knocking on the door saying front desk
front desk
Badger can be seen opening the door and
stepping out into the hallway
who else is in here
the sheriff's deputy then walks inside
and calls for nikum to raise his hands
show me your hands right now
show me your hands right now but instead
of showing his hands nikum opens fire
hands
shots fired the sheriff's deputy puts
out a shots fired call on his radio
after returning fire
shots fired when a SWAT team arrived
they found nicum dead inside the
bathroom with an apparent self-inflicted
gunshot wound right now they're still
searching for Badger reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie